hello freaking campers welcome to this
workshop on declarative gestures and
animations in react native and william
maker of the can athena in reg Nativa
youtube series in this workshop I would
like us to do five things first
to discuss why the topic of gestures and
animations is so popular in react nutiva
and what are the strategies and api's we
are going to use in order to implement
user interactions but run smooth as the
bottom from there we can look at
transitions transitions are the easiest
way to animate components in react
native and we're going to build a
component with two states one state the
cars are overlaid on top of each other
second state they are nicely fanned out
and we are going to declare a transition
to animate nicely from one state to the
other
and then we are going to be the simple
timing animation but we can loop pause
resume pause resume using bare metal
animation api's getting to know these
low-level api's will be the key to
success for her to harness gestures and
animations in react nature and then it
will be time to add gestures into the
mix and we are going to build with nice
wallet user experience so we can swipe
your card nicely and the animate very
nicely depending on their position
finally I would like to show you that
these gestures and animations integrate
very nicely with SVG and we're going to
build this really cool circular slider
using gestures and SVG animations this
workshop will only be scratching the
surface of the exciting world of gesture
and animation in react native and to
conclude I would give you all the
resources but I know of in case you are
interested to go further with this topic
in the video description you will find
the github repository with all the code
examples as well as the boilerplate
files in case you want to code along in
the video and also available in the
video descriptions are the time stamps
for each of the different chapters of
the workshop so freaked out campers are
you ready to discover the powerful world
of technology - shell and animations in
react native let's get started when
building gestures and animations the key
to success is to avoid frame drops we
want the user interaction to run at 60
frames per second which means that we
only have 16 milliseconds to compute
everything and this is a very simple
diagram of the react native architecture
we have the JavaScript Fred which runs
the react code and the UI thread which
interacts with all the native components
and they talk to each other using what
we call the a sync bridge they are
synchronously send each other
Jason messages so if your gesture or
animation relies on communication
between these two threads it is very odd
to guarantee that the animation frame
can be computed within 16 milliseconds
and you are likely to drop frame there
are a couple of reasons for that first
because of these synchronous messages
that needs to be passed and sterilized
you might drop a frame on the low-end
device and the JavaScript thread might
be busy doing something else
for instance processing the response of
an HTTP request so maybe you have a
gesture so the UI thread says to the
JavaScript Fred should I grant the
gesture and the JavaScript Fred might be
busy processing the response of an HTTP
request so it's not able to reply
within these 16 milliseconds and you're
gonna drop a frame and user experience
is not going to feel very smooth so the
way we are going to circumvent this
problem is by declaring all of our
gestures and animations beforehand which
means that there is no communication
between the JavaScript thread and the UI
thread so it doesn't matter if the
JavaScript phrase is busy doing
something else because the UI thread is
going to be able to do all the tasks he
needs to do for each frame and plus
because there is no communication
between the two threads we are sure that
we are able to compute the animation
frame within with 16 milliseconds and I
would like to show you an example of
what this means concretely so here I am
dragging around with a component and we
implemented this example using the
default gesture and animation API
provided by react native I call it
vanilla animation API ISM and as you can
see here the gesture Japan's realized on
communication between the JavaScript
thread and the UI thread so to grant the
gesture we need to execute some
JavaScript thread when we move view
around here everything is done on
because we use this animated event
everything is done on the UI thread so
there is no communication between the
JavaScript and the native side and when
we release the gesture we also rely on
JavaScript code and so because we have
this mix of imperative code and
declarative code if the JavaScript
thread is busy this user interaction is
not gonna run
smoothly and in fact what I can do is to
modify the code so that we have the
JavaScript Fred we make the JavaScript
Fred busy so I'm gonna loop 5,000 time
and maybe like print something like GS
Fred busy and now you see I cannot move
the ball around because the JavaScript
fred is busy and so we are not going to
use these api's because visa api is rely
on communication between the UI thread
and the JavaScript thread and what we're
going to use instead so is two libraries
react native reanimated for animations
and react native gesture and for
gestures and what this library too is
that they enable you to implement all
the gesture and animations declaratively
on the UI thread which means that when
you have your gesture and animation
running there is no communication
between the two Fred's bodies involved
so here if I make the JavaScript Fred
busy it doesn't matter because there are
no communications between the UI thread
and the JavaScript thread so this is the
same implementation but using the class
here gestures and animations using react
native - handler and react native
reanimating them and now so everything
is done declaratively
and I can make the JavaScript Fred busy
up so GS
busy
so now
is running but because I don't rely on
the JavaScript Fred you see I can still
move the ball around smoothly and so
this is the heart of the matter
declaring all the gestures and
animations beforehand and this will
guarantee us to build user experiences
that will run at 60fps even on low-end
devices in this example I would like to
show you the power of transitions in
react native app transitions as a
easiest way to animate components in reg
Nativa and the way it works is that we
can attach an animation value to a
change of state in a component so here I
have a very simple component with a very
simple state Togolese true offers if the
toggle is true we apply here a rotation
which is index minus 1 times alpha so
alpha is 30 degrees pi is 180 degrees
divided by 6 and here I do index minus 1
minus 1 times alpha so if index is 0 0
minus 1 is minus 1 times 30 degrees so
we'll have minus 50 degrees if index is
1 so the count in the middle we would
have 1 minus 1 0 times 40 degrees 0 so
there won't be any rotation if it's the
third card we will have index 2 2 minus
1 is 1 so we have 30 degrees so we see
here here we have the cards constants
which contains 6 cards we select free
and we calculate the rotation when
pressing this button we toggle the state
so to its opposite value and so if
toggle is first we have rotation of 0
and what we can do here is to use a hook
could use a transition that will give us
an animation value that will go from 0 1
when toggle changes so if toggle is
forced the
admission value will be 0 if toga is won
the animation value will be 1 and the
way the transition from 0 to 1 1 to 0
gas can your timing function can be a
spring function and can be any
configuration of the animation functions
but you want so let's get this animation
value here we're going to call it
transition and we're going to use a
function called use transition use
transition comes from a package called
react native read ash so we are going to
use react native reanimated and react
native gesture handler for the
declarative gestures and animations and
I created an open-source package called
react native read ash I see it as being
the low dash of reanimated that provides
us with a lot of utility functions such
as this use transition hook but you
don't have to be intimidated by hits
these are just helper functions on top
of reanimated ingestion and now you can
look at the source code of some of these
functions to see how it works behind the
scene but these are usually very simple
helper functions so this function takes
two arguments the first is the state we
want to transition on and here it's
toggle and then we can pass the
animation configuration so for instance
here IO by default juice transition is
using a timing function and maybe I want
the duration to be 400 you can set some
easing you can have a spring function
instead so here we have a transition and
what we want to do is to interpolate the
rotation based on the transition so here
you see we have the view component here
we use animated view animated that view
is a Nanna mation wrapper around view so
that in these style properties we can
use animation values so here we pass a
string which is a rotation value in
radians but now because we use animate
the view this style property can also
accept animation values so here I will
rotate is gonna become an animation
value and we are gonna interpolate it
using transition so you say so we can
write it using interpolate from react
native renovated so the animation value
is a transition input range is 0-1 an
output range is if toggled is 0 the
rotation is 0 if toggle is 1 the
rotation is index minus 1 times alpha so
I need to import interpolate let's have
a look so you see here it nicely
transitions from one state to the other
looks very cool again speaking of LPR
functions
INRI - we are gonna have a lot of these
animation values that go from 0 to 1 and
we're going to interpolate always from 0
to 1 there is a helper function called
called mix in Reed ash so here we input
mix for me - and it's the same
implementation as mix in OpenGL so we
can pass directly the output range like
this so from 0 to index minus 1 times
alpha so just a nice shortcut and yeah
it is and the last thing we can do is to
change the transformation of origin so
here you see by default is the centre of
the card and the way we transform the
origin in react native using the
transform API is that we are gonna
translate to where so from the centre of
origin to where we want a new origin to
be do the transformation and translate
back so here we want to translate to
so the default origin is earth of the
weave of the card half of the ight of
the cat we want to translate to minus
alpha of the wheel of the card do the
transformation translate back to half of
the weave of the card so we're going to
write translate X is minus card we've
divided by 2 we do the transformation
which is rotate and translate back so
translate X is card we've divided by 2
and so here you see it nicely changes
the transformation of origin and here
again we have a nice utility function
INRI - to perform such transformation of
origin is called transform origin and
the first parameter is a new
transformation or Regina so here we have
X which is - card divided by 2 y is 0 we
don't change it and the transformation
is rotate
and so here it is
so transitions are a great way to
animate components in react native we've
little to zero knowledge of gestures and
animations so just a great way to
animate changes in your component States
[Music]
this example we are going to build a
simple timing function using the bare
metal API is from reanimated and getting
to know these low-level api's will
enable us to bid incredible user
experiences so here I have a chat bubble
component but text progress property
which goes from 0 to 1 so this is the
state at 0 we can look at the state at
0.5 1 and so we're going to go from 0 to
1 1 to 0 and there is a state play which
is true or false
so we want this looping timing function
to be possible and resumable nicely and
in order to implement this timing
function we are going to use all the
concepts that react native reanimated as
to offer or almost all of the concepts
and one of these concepts are clocks so
clocks are animation values which update
that himself across time so by default
the value of a clock is 0 you can invoke
a function called start clock on it and
the every frame the clock animation
where you will update itself with a
timestamp and this is this will end up a
rush to bid animations across time then
there is a stop clock function to stop
the clock so the clock animation value
will stop updating itself and as I see
from John called clock running to check
if the clock
running or not and so the way you can
create a clock is like this so it's
clock from reanimated we want here
because we're gonna have many rear
Enders when the state changes we want we
don't want to recreate a new clock every
time we want the clock identity to match
the life cycle of the component so we
want to always have the same clock for
the every instance of a timing component
and so we can use a helper function for
that again from Ray - which is used
clock and here for progress we can use
an animation value so you would do new
value yes zero from again react native
animated but we also want the identity
to be preserved across rear Enders so
we're going to use use value from
readers and these are simple wrappers
using a lazy use ref to have so I need
to import from my - so
what we are going to do is that we're
going to use a hook called use card
which allows us to declare animation
nodes to be run for every frame on the
UI thread
so the function signature the hook
signature is very similar to use effect
the first document is a callback that
returns here an array of animation not
the second parameter are the
dependencies here we have none we want
this this animation nodes to have also
the same lifecycle man of timing
component and so what I'm going to do is
use the clock to controls animation if
the clock is not running the animation
is paused
if the clock is running the animation is
running and so by default Ian we're
going to want the animation to run so
we're going to use a start clock and
what we're going to do is assign to the
progress value some timing function to
some function that we are going to call
run timing and pass the clock as
parameter so let's create it here so run
timing is a function that receives a
clock as parameter and we're going to
return some progress that you execute
also a bunch of animation nodes so you
can use a block in order to do that text
on the array of animation nodes as
parameter and we'll execute this
animation nodes sequentially so maybe I
returned 0 so the last node in the array
the value that is returned and so you
know you see here I'm not writing
progress equal run timing because these
are not imperative instructions that are
run on the JavaScript read but
declarative animation nodes to be
executed on the UI friend
so this is here it's not a cut that is
executed but it's a declaration for code
to be executed on the UI thread so we
are not going to use the if-else syntax
from JavaScript we are going to use a
condition animation node we are not
going to use equal but set animation odd
and so on so we animated provide us with
all the animation nodes we need in order
to declare complex animation States and
interactions on the UI friend so let's
right a run timing function so I need to
import this one from random it's hidden
so if we look at the timing function
from react natira animated we see that
it takes three parameters the clock so
to you know see where how we evolved
across time the animation state so
finished position your position will be
from 0 to 1 right time and a friend time
so I last clock values for the last
evaluation and 0 to 1 if the animation
is finished or not and then the
animation configuration so the target
value duration easing so you see if you
are familiar to the vanilla animated API
or from reg natira
it's a bit more complex to execute a
simple timing function but this so the
barrier to entry Ziya but this is way
more powerful functions so this is why I
really want us to look at the lower
level of all these functions work
because this will enable us down the
road to go much much further because
these functions are incredibly powerful
so let me
copy paste here the function so timing
from relatively limited and so the clock
we get as parameter let's create the
state created ear state so I'm gonna
assign an animation value for each state
[Music]
position frame time time and we have the
config so two value we are gonna update
it depending right two value is if the
position is zero the position is gonna
be our starting value if the starting
value is zero the destination value is
one and if the position is one of the
destination value is going to be zero
duration I don't know let's put three
seconds and easing we can put whatever I
think in out
it does not like the configuration
so I have how is the syntax of the
easing
you
you
yeah I'm import
from vanilla react native but I need to
import the one from reanimated so vast
should because this is where typescript
is so useful so here we execute the
timing function for every frame and what
we want to return is the position so
state dot position so we see it animates
nicely from 0 to 1 at 1 nothing happens
so what at 1 what we need to do so if
state dot finish equals 1
so you see here we are not right again
we are not racing the if/else because
this is not JavaScript code that is
executed imperatively this is a
declaration so we use condition
animation nod that is a declaration to
run on the UI thread so if the state of
the animation is finished we want to
reset this animation values position we
will live but we need to update the true
value so let me reset the state so is
finished is 0 we want to loop frame time
time we reset as well because when
restarting the animation position we
keep if it's 1 it's still 1 we want to
continue where we were so state that
time but what we want to change is the
destination value so config to value is
going to be the opposite of state dot
position if position is 0 the true value
is 1 if position is 1 the true value is
0 so here I need to import these nodes
so you see it loops nicely from 1 to 0
and now from 0 to 1 now let's make the
animation interruptible so you see here
you might be under the impression but
this is a lot of boilerplate code to
write a simple looping animation there
are utility animation functions in
reader that allows you to do these in a
few lines of code because all this
boilerplate can be done for you but I
find to be extremely understand
important to understand how these clocks
and animation evaluation work because
this can really unlock the power of
complex declarative gestures and
animations as we run at 60fps so this is
why here we are doing all the
boilerplate manually so here we have the
state play which becomes true offers and
the first thing I want to do is to have
an animation value that matches the
state of play so if play is true I want
my animation value to be one if plays
force my nation value to be zero so here
we're gonna create a animation where you
card is playing so default value is 0
you know default state is force so
that's good and we're going to create a
hook or again use called hook
but we set the animation where you is
playing to match the state of the play
variable so and you see here I could
write it here in new squad but I'm I'm
having different dependencies now so let
me show you so I do is playing so if
place through it's one if not zero and
here the dependencies is play
so when play changes this instruction
changes because it depends on the play
viable and this is why I'm putting it
into a separate used cut block because I
don't want to have a dependency on the
play viable idea what I'm gonna write
the instructions I'm gonna declare here
are valid for the or lifetime of the
component so I don't want to recreate
these animation nodes if the play viable
as changed only is plain
so now we should have the East playing
variable that matches the state of the
component and so we're gonna tell that
actually so we're going to write two
conditions so the first condition is if
the states of the animation is playing
and the clock is not running so not
clock running and here you see you have
to count the parentheses we want to
start the clock we want to start the
animation and the other way around if
the animation is not playing and the
clock is running we want to stop the
clock
so I need to import stock large and the
end
let's have a look so here I play and I
can pause resume and you see it doesn't
resume at the proper state but I can
pause and I can start the animation but
when I restart the animation the state
of the animation is screwed up
pardon my french so here if the clock is
not running
[Music]
so if we post the animation we want to
reset the time viable of the state so
that when it resumes it resumes the
animation properly and if not we run the
timing function
so let's pause and night resumes exactly
where it was pause super and it loops
nicely so a really cool timing function
but so very low-level API is clogs and
all these complex animation states but
these are really these low-level
primitives are really worth it in order
to be a complex user interactions and
we've seen how we don't write imperative
JavaScript code but use these animation
nodes which are declarations on the UI
thread and sew all the primitives we
have in JavaScript if and not we can the
semicolon to have sequential
instructions so we have the block here
so we have equivalent for all the
javascript construct as animation nodes
and the only construct that is so you
can have viable assignments sequin
shorts executions condition or not the
only primitive that is not available are
loops but here but that's okay because
here it's good to be evaluated for every
frame so I hope you enjoyed this example
if this makes sense to you then you
really have unlocked the power of
declarative gestures and animations if
you are able to to switch from the
imperative mindset to the declarative
mindset and understand how you can use
clocks and animation States in order to
build different user interactions then
the world of animations and gestures in
reg native is your oyster I think you
can really go very far with these
primitives
[Music]
we have looked at transitions animations
now let's play around with the gesture
we have a bunch of cards here and let's
assign some gesture handler to be scales
and play around see what we can do and
so here I'm looping over my cards and
maybe what I can do here is wrap a pan
gesture handler from
react native gesture laughs so we can
maybe move these cards around and we
need to pass two properties for
suggestion I'd love to walk and we're
gonna have used again the utt so it's
quite some boilerplate so there's a lot
of animation values to be created
atchoo properties to be assigned on
congestion on there so we are going to
use utility function again from readers
in all that well all these boilerplate
done for us but you know again don't be
intimidated you can look at the read
ashore squad or ads react native journal
of source code to see you know what kind
of boilerplate is required for this
gesture and love to to work but we're
gonna get the gesture and love and
function called use and gesture handler
and it gives us a couple of viable
suggestion law that we can assign the
ear and the translation vector of the
card the velocity so when we release the
gesture as a velocity of the gesture and
the state of the gesture is a gesture
active is a gesture began and and so you
know we assigned the pan gesture now I
probably need to move key yeah and the
pan gesture handler texts a single
children which needs to be an animated
you from reanimated so yeah we use
animated view from react native
reanimated so we get the translation
vector here I think we can assign it to
this transformation to see if we can
move the card around so we're going to
use a transform and there is a utility
function in reader called translate
where we can give it a vector
and it will apply translate X translate
why a simple shortcut so here I can move
the cards around but I should create one
pan gesture na for each gesture and
laughs and we're just gonna move it here
so you see I can move the card but now
if I start the gesture again it starts
from the original position so we need to
save the position in an offset value
when the gesture ends and again in a
hurry - we have a utility function for
that so may create translate x equals
we've offset
and the first parameter is animation
value and the second parameter is the
state of the gesture so that we know
when to say use your set so translate X
we are getting to the same for while
and yeah we're going to place a
transform
so translate X
translate why
let's translation
so yeah I can move the cat around and it
remembers its position across time and
you see when I stop the
gesture it's kind of abrupt there is no
like physical momentum so what we can do
here instead of using we offset we can
use with dk which will add some nice
decay and this is where the velocity
comes into play because the decay is
calculated according to the velocity so
we value s translation X velocity is
velocity dot oops velocity dot X state
is state
so same for my
[Music]
so now you see you have this nice up
nice momentum when moving the couch and
you see its interruptible as well so now
let's have a nice roulette animation
using these concepts of pan gesture
Handler and DK so I'm gonna move this
outside the loop and we're gonna move
the pan gesture now to be unique to view
and we want to translate on me on the x
axis actually so just want to scroll we
just want to nice the scroll cards so
something is not working because we
forgot as I mentioned the single child
needs to be an animated view but what
I'm gonna do because I want to keep
this one I think I'm gonna wrap it here
and put an animated
you
let's see how it looks
haha it's not translate eggs but
translate y-yeah
you
so it translates nicely and we have like
the nice momentum effect from DK so now
we want to clamp the values we're going
to use a function called diff clamp so
it clamps diff clamp claims the value we
were mean max but we call it diff clamp
meaning that you know if we go to minus
100 pixels just the Delta of one pixel
will be taken into account so it's with
it's much more responsive if you want if
you squirt far back in one of the lower
upper bound and want to go back to one
of the within the bounds of the word
clamping so we're going to add diff
clamp here
and yes there is a trick so there's
currently a bug in the diplom
implementation of reanimated so we're
going to use zip clamp from radar so in
order to not have this burger so the
maximum value is zero right when we are
at these states
yeah and the minimum value is gonna be
so the length so the it--of all these
cards - this right here so this would be
- cards dot length times child height
which we have defined here perfect - the
container height which we calculate
using on layout so let's have a look so
here so you see this is where diff
clamps comes in if I use only clamps so
here I'm scrolling scrolling scrolling
scrolling scrolling then if I want to
score back like this I would have to do
all the opposite scrolling what I did
but even though here maybe I'm like 500
pixel right now can just immediately go
back up and this is what diff clamp does
I mean I can show you quickly with clamp
so iam scrolling down scrolling down
scrolling down scrolling down scrolling
down if I want to scroll up again I need
to scrub scrub scrub scrub scrub and
nice coarse apps with D clamps diff
clamps it's gonna be automatic scroll
down scroll down scroll down but you see
immediately scroll up and let's look
so the lower bound is not correct it
split plus container eight sorry so zero
and perfect
very cool
so now let's animate our cards so maybe
we want to add
so we want actually now
we're going to clamp so I'm gonna call
this Y so if the cow does reach the top
I don't want it to go above I want to
clamp its its value so
translate why
we're going to interpolate from the y
animation value
so the import range goes from
zero and
if we translate to
zero eight zero if it's - can't weave so
that would be - card so can eights or
eight times index so this would be a
cramping value so the output range would
be the same value but we're going to use
extrapolate clamp meaning so this should
be the maximum value the card that can
go so to not go outside the screen and
so by using so here we use linear
interpolation these values match month
one but when we are we have a value for
instance that is lower than - card eight
times index we want to be at
- card eight times index not a lower
value so we are going to write
extrapolate extrapolate dot clamp let's
have a look so we see the count moves on
top of each other you can even add maybe
just you know if you want to build some
effects here maybe it's - card eight
plus sixteen
or -16 sorry you see you're 24 now so
you already have like here a nice well
it animation so now we want to calculate
the position of each card and so the
position Y is
why plus index times card right and
we're going to use this value to do a
couple of interpolations so if the card
is disappearing its position is at least
at least - height so from minus 0 to
minus 8
- can I turn right so the here the card
its position is 0 so if the card is on
top its position is 0 if the cards at
the bottom here so what is the position
on bottom
it's
the number of visible cards in the
screen times the height of the counter
so there would be visible cards times
card ID what are the number of visible
cats
so visible cards we do a mass flow of
the container right
/ card eight
and so this is the number of visible
cats
so this is so - one
a range and ease appearing is a number
of visible cards x can't hide
so is but Tom
[Music]
is appearing
so now we can create some scale
transformation
so the scale of the card so we
interpolate from position why
so the input range is is disappearing is
on top is on bottom
and is appearing and the animation
values are so 0-5 its disappearing 1 1
if it's in the visible range so and 0-5
when it's appearing let's try that
so here you see it disappears nicely in
the background and it appeals nicely
here what we can do is add some clamping
that looks good let's add some opacity
so same story for opacity so I can just
add it here and here
one perfect actually same value no
what we want to do here is to not clamp
I think so you see disappears nicely and
so one thing we can fix is you see when
the card appears it's too far away from
the top card it it's not super smooth so
we can add some extra translation here
so here we can add so you see why we
don't do a plus again we're using the
add animation node so let's call it
extra translation why so which we're
going to interpolate from position while
so actually let me move this up so we
interpolate from
position Y so input range so we go from
is is on bottom to is appearing output
friend
so at bottom the translation is zero at
is appearing we want we know that at is
appearing the size is scale is 0 5 so
the height is can't I divided by 2 and
we want to move it by Alf of the cam ID
so it's gonna be card height divided by
4 and of course here we want to clamp so
we don't want to go outside these values
extrapolate let's have a look
no it's not it's -
count
eight divided by four and you see now it
looks very cool and one thing we can do
here and not you see the scroll
is not completely over so we don't want
to stop the scroller on I am being very
picky but it doesn't feel nice that the
end score position is this
so the last card should be at least as
the full position so here maybe instead
of
container we can do visible cards
now what
to lose
so we had
right
let's try busy broadcast times card
eight yes so that looks good so yeah and
square position looks much nicer so you
see a pretty cool user interaction using
the pan gesture and from react native
just showing low but then of course tons
of different user interactions you can
build using these api's but I hope that
this nice well at user interactions
really gave you some inspiration on the
kind of gestures and animations you can
build using this API so gestures and
animations we just looked at integrate
seamlessly with react native SVG and
this allows for an interesting range of
fun and creative user experiences and
components and this is thanks to an
incredible community and open-source
work right so we looked at react native
- Chandler react native reanimated which
allows us to declare animations on the
UI thread and then there has been a
tremendous amount of open source and
community work which has been spent in
order for these libraries to nicely
integrate with react native SVG and so I
would like to show you a simple example
which is going to be a circular slider
so here we have a SVG circle he has a
circular progress and so we have the
white one here and we're gonna animate
the stroke of this one too
to show some some progress and here we
have a cursor component which we are
going to be able to move around and its
value will always fit the bounds of the
circle so here we have theta animation
value and we are going to move the
cursor around to update this value so
theta goes from zero this is the
position at zero actually here we have a
rotate of minus ninety degrees so zero
is gonna be here let me remove this one
for now so we're gonna have the zero
here we move pi minus pi zero and so
maybe here we're gonna normalize because
this goes from zero to pi minus pi zero
we're gonna normalize it to go from zero
to two pi 360 degrees and the way we're
gonna do it we are gonna set so we have
the theta value 0 this will set the
position of the cursor onto the circle
horn we're gonna do it well we have
three coordinate systems to work with in
react native there's a canva coordinate
system so there is a x-axis which goes
from the left to right and the y-axis
which goes from top to bottom pieces of
canvas coordinate system then there is a
Cartesian coordinate system where we
have a center of origin somewhere here
Center is gonna be the middle of the
circle and the y axis goes from 0 from
bottom to top so the opposite of the
candle axis which goes from top to
bottom and then we have the x axis which
is identical goes from left to right
mr. Cartesian coordinate system the felt
coordinate system is polar coordinate
system so here we also have an original
and given x and y value in the Cartesian
coordinate system we are going to get
anger in a theta value in radians and a
regice so we take
the anger we convert it to the so we
have a polar coordinate so we have a
radius and an angle we can convert it to
a canva coordinate which will give us X
and white position on the canvas so that
will position the cursor onto the circle
then we move the circle around so we
have x and y coordinate which we can
transform to a polar coordinate in order
to know the angle theta and so we can
assign the theta value which we drive
the animations of the stroke value and
also maybe we can animate the color of
the progress so maybe we want green at
the beginning red at the end and so if
you've gone my youtube channel I will
put the links in the video description I
have videos on how we can convert from
one coordinate system to the other
here we're going to use again UTG
functions from reddish to seamlessly go
from one to the other so let's get
started so we are going to start with
our cursor and and once we have so the
cursor is going to write the theta value
and once we have it working we will look
into animate the circular progress
component that we have here so let's
look at the cursor so the first thing
we're going to do is to wrap a pan
gesture and layer so we can move it
around so pan gesture anger from react
native Jess Chandler
and we need the gesture in there we're
going to use a helper function from me -
so gesture I'll use panda Chandler and
we're gonna get translation vector and
the state of the gesture oops some time
for you and so here we're gonna have
some translate but what so what we want
to do we okay let's add some translate
so translate X we're going to use so we
want to remember the position across
different gestures so we're going to use
we've offset also translate X state and
translate y of translate y
of translation let me apply the
transformation translate X translate Y
so I can move the cursor around so pair
but night needs to be you know whatever
is the position within the bounds of the
circle so this is where we need to
convert these values into polar
coordinates so create X Y and we have a
center vector which is the middle of the
screen so let me create
a vector so Center is axis we've divided
by two
while is height divided by two which we
need to import from the dimensions API
so we have we've right from dimension
get window
so let's convert
into polar coordinates so we have por la
equals so he B is a Cartesian so we're
gonna use Cartesian to polar if you
enter the math behind this is a function
is super interested I have some videos
on this topic so if you are interested I
definitely recommend you check it out so
first argument is the point so we have
XY
and
[Music]
we probably need to cut it no pull out
no Cartesian to polar that's correct
and so we get
the theta angle which we can assign to
this animation value the regice regice
doesn't matter what we need to do is to
set the radius to be the edges of our
circle and convert back these
coordinates to Cartesian coordinates so
we are going to have X translate X
why translate why so we are going to
convert polar to Cartesian
theta is Paula dot theta no problem but
Regis is not the Regis of our cursor but
the radius of the circle so that will
bound the cursor to only move around the
circle and the second parameter should
be for love to coordinate to Cartesian
no it looks good
is this regice regice is so you see we
have an issue so translate x with the
center the origin of so I think I should
set center here sorry okay
it's not Cartesian to pull out but
convert to power my mistake
so convert to pro laughs and we can set
the center of origin here so the center
and here it's convert to polar to
convert I was confused why it didn't
need to use the center of origin the
origin that didn't make any sense
so now still actually it doesn't work we
have a wheel so actually here the center
because it's not
the container this is not the window but
the content which is the size here this
container of the circus over here I put
background color red so you see
off-center is not right of the screen /
- but rages and rages so let me update
this so Center
he's regice
and
you
so now it animates nicely so now we need
to set the theta value and so you could
set the value to be pull out the data
directly but put our theta goes from
zero to pi and minus PI to minus zero so
here the value would be minus pi divided
by two and not a free quarter of two
paese
so we want to normalize the value to go
from zero to two pi so we're gonna
create use code and we're going to
assign
up
tada
to be poor loud
but we need to normalize data
so normalize data we take data so as an
animated nod so if theta is less than
zero so it's minus zero minus pi we need
to add two pi so theta is less than zero
its theta plus 2 pi if not it's the
theta value so from 0 to PI theta is
okay and now if let's say we have minus
PI minus PI plus 2 pi would be 2 pi 3/4
of two PI's so it's going to be 2 pi
minus alpha 1 pi so this should gives us
proper values for theta and here let's
see we are going to interpret the column
data to see what we we get so let's use
interpolate so colors are numbers and we
have interpolate color functions in
reddish so we can interpolate on theta
and so input range so theta goes from 0
to 2 pi so we have 0 let's say PI and 2
pi we're gonna use three colors orange
we can use star guide palette secondary
primary and primary
and - Irish
let's have a look
so see how the color updates nicely
so now let's animate or
as VG circle and
we're gonna use - stroke array to
animate the progress of the circle so we
want to - chakra way to be safe
conference of the circle so we want one
empty stroke to be the circumference of
the circle one full stroke to be the
circumference of the circle so we can
animate really from zero completely
empty to one completely full so the
circumference of the circle is 2 pi
times the radius and the length of the
arc of circle is going to be regice
times the theta right and so this can be
the offset the - stroke offset so let's
so we need to calculate the
circumference which is gonna be 2 pi
times radius which we get e is as
property so we can assign - stroke array
to dish
so circumference circumference and we
can calculate the so here okay so the -
stroke offset and here so we're gonna
have a couple of animation values it's
not a circle but an animated sacral and
animated circle we use the create
animated components in order to have the
rub animated wrapper but can accept
animation values as property so now we
need to calculate stroke - offset which
is actually the same formula and here
but instead of having the full angle
which is 2 pi er we have we use data so
it's going to be multiplied beta by
Aegis let's look it looks good but also
very strange so the stroke
Cola appears to be good
like one color
[Music]
you
we need to add stroke we've
and now there is a strange
of set value here
so here it looks like at zero it's
correct and then there is you see some
offset value what goes further and
further
and I think here I wrote it down because
I wrote
is the radius - stroke we've divided by
two
that makes sense because we want the
center to be here so I should probably
replace radius
yeah now that looks good
it's fun isn't it
I could play with this always for hours
but really a nice example of how
gestures and animations seamlessly
integrate with each other free code camp
URLs I hope you enjoyed this workshop on
declarative gel animations in react
Nativa
let me know what you think in the
comments below if you are interested to
go further with this topic I will link
to resources in the video description we
discussed the heart of the matter why is
this topic so popular in reg native and
the api's and strategies to use in order
to build this very smooth user
experiences we looked at transitions the
easiest way to animate react native
components and then we implemented a
simple timing function using the bare
metal reanimated API and we've built
this timing function to be interruptible
so we can pause resume but also we can
also loop the function across time then
we built a first gesture so we have
discount and we could move them around
and swipe them and we've used gesture
API to build a nice wallet user
interaction and finally we've looked at
how SVG can be used to seamlessly
integrate with these gestures and
animations and that allows for a range
of really fun and creative user
interactions to be built if you want my
youtube channel I have thousands of
videos on this topic for instance in the
case of the SVG example we used
functions which leveraged trigonometry
behind the scene and right where we
converted from polar coordinate system
to canva and vice-versa
I have videos where I really explained
the math behind the scene and
trigonometry is very important in
animation because as soon as you have
something that has some sort of rotation
it's gonna involve trigonometry and I
quite some videos about this topic and I
have also more advanced videos on the
topic of SVG animation for instance you
can use SVG animations to move from one
SVG path to the other and there is a
also really interesting examples with
basic curves that is really we only
scratch the surface there is really tons
of great things you can build using SVG
animations we looked at the pan gesture
under but they are of course different
kinds of gestures in react native tab
projection handler the pinch an unlevel
rotate gesture Allah and I also have
videos on these topics I will link to
these resources in the video description
and we use the transform API to move
things around and we even did
transformation of origin the transform
API from react native is incredibly
powerful and with not even looked at all
the things it has to offer and I also
have videos on these topics on how to
build advanced 2d transformations how to
save as a state of complex
transformations across the gestures and
I even have a video where we go to the
third dimension so if you are interested
I hope that you will check it out so I'm
really looking forward to talk to you
soon and the meantime happy hacking
[Music]
minus PI minus PI plus 2 pi would be 2
pi 3/4 of two pies so we would have so
minus PI plus 2 pi is
by
but so far - PI / 2 so minus PI / 2 + 2
pi is gonna be 3/4 of PI of 2 pi so it's
gonna be 2 pi minus alpha 1 pi